[Music]
greetings dear friends thank you so much
for joining our program today I'd like
to
know uh this is a question and answer
program where you send us your questions
and we do the research and do everything
possible to answer the questions that
you send us we want to encourage you to
continue sending questions we receive
many many of them we're not able to
answer them uh quickly because we have
so many but we put them in the order in
which they come in and then we answer
them so stay tuned we will get to your
question eventually and hopefully
provide a Biblical answer Spirit of
Prophecy answer that you're satisfied
with the research that we've done uh let
me give you the address where you can
send us your questions it's an
electronic address
tvsm tv.org you can see it on the screen
tvsm
tv.org so we encourage you to send us
your questions we love to do the
research and we love to answer them I
have with me Pastor David Salasar who is
a member of our staff here uh he's in
charge of our Spanish speaking work uh
which we're producing more and more even
a Sabbath School class now praise the
lord lord for a long time we didn't have
one but uh he's LED in making sure that
our Spanish-speaking people uh also have
a Sabbath school program among many many
other things thank you for being on the
program today thank you Pastor as always
a privilege to be with you here praise
the lord well we have some very engaging
questions today absolutely but uh we
want to ask the Lord Lord's guidance uh
because we should never open the holy
book without the help of the holy spirit
amen so would you pray for us please
absolutely Pastor let's pray Heavenly
Father we come once again before you to
seek your Holy Spirit to ask that you
will send it to us that we will receive
the direction the influence the guidance
of your special gift the holy spirit so
that we may be able to teach not our own
thoughts but your word and be able to
bring uh the truth to those that are
watching that they may bring uh to them
a closer relationship with the Lord a
closer walk with thee we pray that you
be with us now we pray this in Jesus
name amen amen well we have a very very
interesting question that I've never
seen before yeah and um let me ask it
and then we'll have you answer okay
question the question is this it comes
from South Africa from an individual
called CI culi I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly this is the question so
concerning the
tithe is it only food for the pastors
and not the maintenance people musicians
who serve in the church why are the
Levites exclusive to pastors if someone
studied music or Plumbing is it right
for them to go out into the world so
that they can make a living when they
could serve like Pastors in the
church uh so I think the question is
self-explanatory so what can we say to
this question which is not technically a
Biblical question although we could say
that the the Bible does say what the
tithe is to be used for so how do we
approach this okay thank you Pastor and
thank you for our friend who's watching
and trying to get this question I could
imagine that there is you know in the
Bible we know that the L
were people that were was actually the
tribe that was separated to serve the
Lord they did not have a possession they
did not have an inheritance and so God
gave them the inheritance to be the
ministers for him in the Min in the
ministry of the of the sanctuary that
included musicians that included the
taking care of the aspects not just the
ceremonial aspects but the physical
aspects of uh portraying and containing
and and doing the things with the
sanctuary or the temple also they were
to be teachers they were supposed to be
the ones that instructed all the other
tribes in the knowledge of the Lord and
so in these situations we know that the
they were just not just priests if you
will they were also like we said
musicians and teachers and those that
were assisting the education of the
children of Israel now it's important to
understand that the principle of Tiding
in today
experience in today's uh system is not
going to be exactly the same because we
don't have priests and we don't have a
tribe anymore but the principles of what
they were to do really applies to us
today we have Bible teachers Bible
instructors we have of course Ministers
of the Gospel the ones that preach and
those that are teaching the instructions
of the Lord but uh God sort of gave us
guidelines so that those that are
involved in the actual proc claiming of
the message and teaching of God's word
those are ministers now they don't have
to be all pastors and I think this may
be an assumption of our friend that is
maybe a little Mis mistaken uh because
the church uh the tithe that is given to
the church is does not only pay the
pastor's salary it pays the
administrators it pays the uh those that
are laboring even some of our teachers
Spirit prophecy speaks of that teachers
that teach the Bible were to receive
tithing or where to be paid through the
Tiding and uh I believe that there is
specifically four uh characteristics or
categories categories that the lord gave
the spirit you know the Ser of the Lord
white to give us a guidance of who these
individuals could receive uh income from
Tiding and they were Ministers of Bible
workers this is actually found in
evangelist in the in the book evangelism
page 492 Bible teachers inner
educational institutions this is
actually founding testimonies for the
church page volume 6 page 215 we also
have needy Mission fields in North
America and around the world like
Mission fields that have needs where
also to receive tithes if needed and
also medical missionaries Physicians
that are doing also the teaching aspect
of of the word of God and finally
retired gospel workers so those that
have Labor through all their life and
now are retired they also should be
receiving from the tithing a portion now
anybody else that may be involved in in
the work you know he mentions people
that do uh maintenance you know work or
musicians I I don't know I think the
musicians probably could be but that's
something that I don't think that has
been really done some research but I I
do believe that biblically maybe
musicians who are 100% dedicated to the
work of God in proclaiming the word
through music should perhaps be included
yeah the levite were musicians were the
musicians of Israel right and they were
the ones that received the tithe so I
think that you're on the right track yes
unfortunately the church maybe not doing
this particularly well or maybe this has
not been really studied completely or
has not being embraced rightly but
musicians that are preach are singing
the truth and preaching or preaching
through the music should be considered
part of those that receive uh money but
anybody else that are for example those
that take care of the poor or uh
education regular education or operating
in schools uh wages for literature
evangelist all these things that were
extra aside from these four main
characteristics those were not to be
paid with tithing but through offerings
and so that could include somebody that
is working in the church as a
maintenance worker as somebody that is
doing you know clerical work that kind
of thing those are to be paid through
offerings but I believe that the the
word the Bible has been kind of clear in
this fact that those that teach and
preach and are part are really involved
in the proclaiming of the Gospel in a
one way or the other directly those can
be uh pay with tithing and is not only
men but also women who are also laboring
for the Lord so either both both both
can be yeah we need to
remember that um the position that you
occupy in the church is a calling mhm
it's not a profession correct and in
Ephesians chapter
4 uh it says in verse 11 and he
himself this is Christ he himself gave
some to be Apostles so they would be
paid from the
tithes
prophets Ellen White was paid from the
tithe um some evangelists they're
directly involved in sharing the
gospel pastors and teachers mhm very
similar to the list that that you read
from Ellen White right uh how she says
that the tithe is supposed to be used
now this question seems to imply that
well why are Pastors in a special
category why are they paid from the
tithe the simple reason is that because
in the Old Testament the
Levites worked fulltime mhm to fulfill
the needs of the congregation the
spiritual needs of the congregation they
had no inheritance in Israel right in
fact let me read that yeah uh it's found
in the Book of Numbers chapter
18 and um beginning with verse
21 uh every every tribe received an
inheritance except the tribe of Levi
right because they were supposed to be
full-time ministers to the needs of the
congregation mhm um it says in verse 21
behold I have given the children of Levi
all the tithes in Israel as an
inheritance in return for the work which
they perform the work of the Tabernacle
of
meeting Hereafter the children of Israel
shall not come near the Tabernacle of
meeting lest they bear sin and die but
the Levites shall perform the work of
the Tabernacle of meeting and they shall
bear the iniquity it shall be a statute
forever throughout your Generations that
among the children of Israel they shall
have no inheritance for the tithes of
the children of Israel which they offer
up as a heave offering to the Lord I
have given to the Levites as an
inheritance therefore I have said to
them among the children of Israel they
shall have no inheritance so in other
words their full-time job was to
minister in the sanctuary they were not
out to you know they were not supposed
to go planting wheat and taking of
animals and and all these things uh as a
personal thing uh they were supposed to
minister 100% of the time to uh the
gospel Ministry and the Apostle Paul
picked up on this and said those who
preach the gospel MH are to be
remunerated from the gospel he says in
Corinthians right and so uh in a certain
sense the tithe system continues with
ministers because they work fulltime to
meet the spiritual needs of the church
the spiritual needs of the world even in
in terms for example of evangelists and
you know Pastor you mentioned something
very important the work for the Lord in
Ministry it's a calling is not to be
seen as a profession and I believe that
this is a main important point to make
because you may be called to be a
minister and if you're called to
Ministry you need to be involved 100% of
the time in that aspect now if you are
not called for the ministry and but you
have skills in other areas as you know
our friend mentions plumming for example
you know somebody that's good in
Practical things well you know there is
not much pluming you can do every day of
the week in the church I mean is really
just not possible so what you have to do
is use the time to work but as you labor
in Prof whatever profession you have you
have to remember that you're also as a
witness to the Lord and it gives you the
income through the skills you have have
or the Lord has given you but it's not
like you are less than a minister it's
not like you are lesser person you can
still minister for the Lord in that
aspect just in you know through service
to do a good job the way that people can
say wow this individual is transparent
he does the job you know to conscience
he's not overcharging me and you can
give a much much more evidence a
physical evidence of you know a a
testimony that you are a living
Christian so even though you doing a
business trans section you still can be
a witness to the Lord but you're not
called to that particular aspect of
preaching or teaching the word of God so
this is important you know right around
the corner from our studio is an
automotive shop called honesty
Automotive so just by the sign in front
of their of their business yes they're
witnessing that people who come there
are not going to be overcharged and some
of our people take their automobiles
there and they say that they live up to
what's in front of their store wow and
so um the bottom line is you can be
faithful in any area that you work and
you can be a witness in every area uh to
honesty Integrity amen and uh you can
reveal the spirit of Christ as you deal
with people as well so uh you know
ministers work full-time other people
have other professions uh you know this
would be kind of a boring world if
everybody was a minister it takes a lot
of people different kinds of people to
make the world go around and you know
working for the Lord is not going to
make you rich is not going to make you
wealthy uh if you're if your heart is
for the Lord he's GNA give you enough to
survive but amen and I think that
sometimes people realize don't realize
that working for God is sacrifice it
requires dedication and willingness to
not be drawn by the world or drawn into
this you know things that the world
offers and so it's important to keep
this in mind so that people are not
trying to think that oh me you know
being a minister a pastor is a
profession you know I can make a good
living that's that's not how it works
it's not the purpose of what you know
the Lord made us to be ministers for you
know it's interesting Ellen White makes
it very clear that the tithe for example
is not to be used to help the poor MH
and you say oh well that's kind of
callous you can't use the tithe to help
the poor no because the tithe is rest
restricted mhm in its use yes but she
says the church should be generous in
its offerings to meet the needs of the
poor right so there are
offerings and there's also the tithe it
says in Malachi bring all the tithes and
offerings to the storehouse yeah and so
we need to meet the needs of the poor we
need to uh you know have plumbers in the
church we need to have physicians in the
church we need to have nurses and
dentist in the church and everything but
they're not to be remunerated from the
tithe I know amen okay well I think that
that answers that question let's go to
our next question uh this is a very
interesting one uh you want to read that
absolutely this comes from Rambler a
friend and he says the following
question I'd like to know if neurod
Divergent people like those with autism
ADHD execution function disorders and
the like are able to commune with God if
so is there a difference or a different
approach we need to take in order to
cultivate the relationship with my
savior that I so crave and need I feel
like every time I try to become close to
him my brain actively fights against me
and I don't want my disabilities to
cause me to be broken goods and unusable
for fathering God's purposes how do I
give up the sins I love
and then also lastly could you please
email me to notify me when you are going
to release the answer on your program
yeah um we usually do that we
communicate with Bruce who does our
social media here yeah and uh let him
know that when this airs uh that uh we
need to make sure that the person knows
that it's going to be on the air uh okay
well this is a very interesting question
um you know God takes into account
where we're born the capacities that we
have the environment in which we live MH
and the genetic background that we have
yes I praise the Lord that he takes all
of these things into account and I
praise the Lord that God is only God is
the only judge amen because God knows
the ins and outs of the person and so I
would like to begin by saying that that
you know God does not expect the same
from a person who has autism than from a
person who doesn't yes I don't know if
you want to add something well no just
you know we have examples in the word of
God how Christ healed you know the um
those that had a pulsy of some sort you
know they who were limited either you
know through physical limitations or
mental limitations the Lord knew
remember the example of the father who
said my son has been tormented by a
demon since he was a b baby he will
throw himself into the fire so we could
say that today it would be perhaps
someone with these neurod Divergent
conditions and the Lord knew the Cry of
the soul the heart so I believe like you
said pastor it is a promise to anyone
that wants delivery or wants to have a
closer work with the Lord that he's
listening and he's actively wanting
to heal our hearts our minds from the
consequences from the penalty of sin uh
nevertheless if you know as you
mentioned if God understands our limited
limits and our shortcomings and where we
come from or you know our baggage if you
will he's also making provision and
Grace to grant us the ability to receive
the power and the Deliverance that he
promises God expects much where much is
given mhm is what the Bible teaches
right and and so God does not expect as
much from some people as he does from
others like for example an individual
individual who lives in a country where
for example where Buddhism and Hinduism
uh are the religions uh the person never
had a chance to to know Jesus Christ not
even the name yeah and yet uh Ellen
White states that these will not perish
because the holy spirit is working on
their hearts as well and as long as they
live up
to all of the light that they have God
knows that he can trust additional light
now also in this question uh is the
issue of um how do I give up the sins
that I love and uh this applies not only
to people who are neurod Divergent it
applies to all of us absolutely because
we all have a struggle with sin yeah
every minute of every day um I think
that uh Romans chapter uh uh Hebrews
rather chapter 12 really helps us to
understand how we can overcome sin uh
it's by beholding Jesus permanently says
therefore we also since we are summoned
by so great a cloud of witnesses which
are the heroes of chapter 11h let us lay
aside every weight and the sin which so
easily ens snares us and let us run with
endurance the race that is set before us
now the question is how do we lay aside
every weight and the sin which ens
snares Us and how do we run with
endurance the next verse tells us
looking unto
Jesus the author and finisher of our
faith who for the joy that was set
before him endured the cross despising
the shame and has sat down at the right
hand of the Throne of God so the answer
is looking unto Jesus amen the reason we
sin is because we take our eyes off of
Jesus and that's why Ellen White tells
us that it would be well for us to spend
that thoughtful hour every day uh to
contemplate The Life of Christ
particularly the closing scenes she says
as we do that we will cry at the foot of
the cross but we will also gain
victories in our spiritual life in our
struggle with evil the Apostle Paul even
had this struggle he says what I what
what I know I should do I don't yeah and
what I know I shouldn't do I do uh in
Romans chapter 7 but then he ends
chapter 7 by by saying I thank God for
Jesus Christ who gives us Victory amen
over this so as we commit our ways to
Christ it doesn't matter whether we're
autistic you know there's some very
severe autism and there's some that's
less severe where people are very
functional and I know people uh that fit
both categories right you know God takes
into to account what they know where
they were born the capacities that they
have God is not going to judge them with
the same rule that he judges us right
he's going to take into account their
capacities uh to understand and I'm very
you know thankful that our friend you
know Rambler he's actually able to be
you know come come know clean about his
desire or his love for sin and I think
this is the Lord speaking to his heart
saying you have this love for this
particular sin uh but you got to give it
up and and perhaps one of the things
that I think he needs to do is ask the
Lord to put that enity for that sin and
to help him remove the things that are
keeping the chains of sin in his life
sometimes you may have to make a a a
bold choice and a bold decision to say
you know what I don't know particularly
let's say are the movies that are really
addicted to me you know or is this music
you need to make that choice saying you
you know what it's not just saying Lord
help me but I got to put them away burn
them get you know you know throw them in
the trash there's things that sometimes
we have to do that can help us not to
have this temptation all the time around
us otherwise it's going to be very hard
to to overcome and to have that victory
that we want yeah uh many times when I'm
counseling youth one of the big
questions that comes up is Pastor I'm
struggling with this certain sin how do
I overcome that sin
yeah and so I answer the question with
another question what are you watching
and what are you listening to yeah
because we are physically what we eat
through our mouth yeah we are
spiritually what we eat through our eyes
and through our ears we cannot expect to
gain the victory over sin while we're
watching and listening to the devil's
material yeah because it's going to
contaminate it's going to defile our
mind so we need to have the mind of
Christ and the only way that we can have
that is by only allowing to come through
our eyes and our ears what is
spiritually edifying what is noble and
what is in harmony with God's will amen
amen well folks uh time is um quickly
going into eternity and uh we've come to
the end of our program please send us
your questions we appreciate them very
much we appreciate you God bless you and
we hope to see you at our next program
i' like to know
[Music]